dans l'actualité ce soir la justice
reconnaît pour la première fois le droit
opposable au logement en fin d'après
midi le tribunal administratif de paris
a donné raison à une familles mal logées
dont le dossier avait été rejeté
invité ce soir christine boutin ministre
du logement bonsoir et à tout à l'heure
l'europe donne son accord au versement
d'une petite partie de l'aide d'urgence
aux pêcheurs les marins maintiennent la
pression sur les dépôts de carburants
certaines stations services commencent à
manquer d'essence
le carburant dont le prix devrait encore
augmenter le cours du pétrole a fait un
nouveau bond à 129 dollars et demi le
baril dans ce journal gros plan sur
l'opep qui tient les économies mondiales
dans sa main est ce l'effet du service
minimum les prévisions de trafic pour la
journée de grève de jeudi ne sont pas si
alarmiste
deux tgv sur trois en service un ter sur
deux et une circulation presque normal à
la ratp à l'étranger naples attend sans
illusion la venue de silvio berlusconi
au milieu des montagnes d'ordures
les alertes au feu se multiplient nous
retrouverons deux envoyés spéciaux sur
place
enfin dix jours sans télévision sans
jeux vidéo et sans ordinateur
c'est l'expérience menée par 250 enfants
d'une école en alsace objectif tout
simplement une prise de conscience de la
présence envahissante des écrans bonsoir
et bienvenue à tous
avant de développer ces titres un
document sur la chine nous avons reçu
aujourd'hui huit jours après ces images
d'amateurs tourné au moment même du
séisme elles ont été filmées dans une
école où les élèves donnait une
représentation de théâtre philippe
rochot
le danger pour les rescapés les pierres
qui se détachent des bâtiments et tombe
sur la foule
il est 14h30 à beichuan un million
d'habitants ont cédé à la panique et se
retrouvent dans la rue et bt il tente de
porter secours aux blessés et ne savent
pas où aller
ici des élèves assister à une pièce de
théâtre
plusieurs vont ils trouver la mort
d'autres en sortirons blessés des
enfants surtout des enfants lui sera
rapidement dégagée mais dans l'école
trois élèves appellent au secours les
professeurs les sortirons avec les
moyens du bord
car à cette heure là les secours ne sont
pas encore arrivés les écoles ont été
les premiers bâtiments à s'effondrer
alors que les immeubles officiels ont
résisté au choc thann avec ses 13 ans
nous montre à quel point les matériaux
était friable dans cette seule école 130
élèves sont morts leurs copains ont même
écrit leur nom en lettres de sang
au total sept mille établissements
scolaires ont été détruits par le séisme
et deux millions d'enfants plus ou moins
directement touchés et chaque jour amène
son miracle a aujourd'hui encore un
homme et une femme ont été sauvées des
décombres cette dernière a survécu en
buvant de l'eau de pluie des images
largement diffusées par la télévision
chinoise il faut dire qu'une ambiance de
communion où règnent dans le pays et les
entreprises françaises
épinglé on s'en souvient au moment du
passage de la flamme tente elle aussi la
main aux sinistrés à pékin pascal
golomer sylvain youm pour eux comme pour
des dizaines d'autres salariés l'usiné
doute ionienne est devenu leur refus
c'est l'une des 27 cimenterie que
possède le groupe lafarge en chine il
s'est arrêté au moment du séisme
elle ne redémarrera qu'après un long
travail d'inspection si tout va bien
alors en attendant la vie a repris sur
le parking on y mange on y dort dans des
tentes
car parmi les 400 employés beaucoup
n'ont plus de maison
certains ont perdu des membres de leur
famille leur a ouvert ses portes dès le
premier jour je pense que dans ces
moments là face à une telle catastrophe
c'était vraiment important qu'il ait une
solidarité entre collègues d'une même
équipe
sous les bâches la direction a aussi
installé ses bureaux avec les moyens du
bord pour être prêt à reprendre le
travail
la ville tellement besoin de ciment il
faut que l'on redémarre la production le
plus vite possible
il aura tant à reconstruire à doute
ionienne mais l'urgence pour les
habitants c'est déjà d'être à l'abri et
tout le monde est là ce n'a pas eu la
chance d employés de lafarge s'est
famille emménage aujourd'hui seulement
dans une tente
après une semaine passée dans la rue le
sourire est revenu ici on a plus
d'inquiétude même s'il ya un nouveau
tremblement de terre on ne paniquera pas
la seule chose qui nous inquiète c'est
qu'on ne sait pas quand pourra retrouver
un vrai logement
les autorités estiment à près de 5
millions le nombre de personnes qui ont
perdu leur logement
suite au séisme c'est dire l'ampleur de
la tâche qui reste à accomplir pour que
chacun retrouve à toi même provisoire
dès que possible
on en vient maintenant à cette décision
rendue en fin d'après-midi la justice a
donc reconnu pour la première fois le
droit opposable au logement une familles
mal-logées contester le rejet de son
dossier
les juges ont demandé un réexamen c'est
l'application de la loi de mars 2007
edouard baer jan julie gestel tout a
commencé il ya un an et demi au coeur de
l'hiver l'association les enfants de don
quichotte frappe fort des tentes le long
du canal saint martin à paris
l'objectif alerter l'opinion publique
sur le sort des mal logés
en réponse jacques chirac alors
président de la république
annonce que l'état est prêt à
reconnaître un droit opposable au
logement
en clair la possibilité de recourir à la
justice pour obtenir un toit dans la
foulée une loi est votée le 5 mars 2007
y est juste
principaux concernés les sdf les
personnes hébergées temporairement ou
menacés d'expulsion sans relogement ou
encore les locataires de logements
insalubres
la mère de famille qui vient de se voir
reconnaître son droit opposable au
logement élèves seuls deux enfants de
trois et huit ans elle avait déposé un
dossier auprès de la préfecture de paris
comme ces centaines de familles qui se
pressait début janvier
débouté une première fois elle a saisi
le tribunal administratif
il vient de lui donner raison
aujourd'hui une première
les associations s'en félicite elle
s'était particulièrement mobilisés ces
derniers mois six cent mille personnes
pourraient cette année faire valoir leur
droit au logement opposable
christine boutin ministre du logement et
donc avec nous merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation est ce que vous êtes
surprise par cette décision qui risque
d'ouvrir la voie des milliers de
familles non je pense qu'au contraire
c'est le témoignage que cette loi est en
train de se mettre en application on a
vu distincts possible au logement
opposable c'est compliqué les
commissions de médiation en scène verra
pas le jour et c'est tout est en place
et donc là il se trouve que la
commission de médiation de paris et je
tiens à remercier et féliciter tous les
présidents de commissions de médiation
et les membres parce que c'est un très
gros travail ont décidé à paris sur le
cas de madame fofana qu' elle ne
remplissait pas les deux critères qui
était l'urgence et est donc et qu'elle
était prioritaire alors madame fanta
l'air a fait appel sous forme de référé
et le jugement
le juge samedi il faut réexaminer la
commission de médiation exane mais ça
signifie qu'on devra lui accorder un
logement ça veut ça signifie a deux
solutions la commission de médiation
soit dira d'accord elle est prioritaire
il ya urgence à ce moment là il ya
préfet le préfet devra trouver un
logement sera tenu du décalage dans les
six mois qui viennent et le 1er décembre
2008 là si elles n'étaient pas logés
cette dame à ce moment là il pourrait se
retourner vers l'état qui aurait des
pénalités financières
mais si tout le monde suit cet exemple
si tout le monde est encourageant parce
qu'il ya des gens qu'est ce que ça
signifie qu'il va falloir tout donner
afin de trouver derrière logement
d'abord il ya une bonne surprise c'est
que vous disiez six cent mille personnes
en fait il n'y aura pas 600 mille
personnes
et heureusement au mois de décembre qui
seront dans ces cas d'erreur est
prioritaire puisqu'au 1er au 31 mars
2008 donc trois mois de rahma
d'applications 18 mille dossiers sur
toute la france dont 75% sur la région
ile de france où là il vraiment la
situation est très difficile donc nous
aurons au maximum 120 mille logements en
descend donc ce ne sera pas les 600000
et nous nous mettons et les préfets se
mettre en route pour faire en sorte que
tout le monde puisse être logés et moi
je demande au préfet de mettre à la fois
le les hlm et le secteur prisé en marche
pour que tout le monde soit logé
on comprend que c'est une étape 1 dans
le processus que les préfectures sont
pas mises en demeure immédiatement de
trouver un logement à cette famille mais
que ça sera le cas en décembre et c'est
ce que tout le monde sera prêt à ce
moment là avait coûté ont réservé un
sort on va faire en sorte que le maximum
de réponse soit donnée car il est
inadmissible que la france ne loge pas
tous ces enfants en face est absolument
scandaleux effectivement la grand
problème de notre pays c'est de
construire il faut construire et
construire encore car il n'y a pas
suffisamment de logements en particulier
dans la région ile de france merci
christine boutin d'être venu répondre à
nos questions le conflit des pêcheurs je
vous le disais l'europe a donné un
premier feu vert pour le versement d'une
petite partie de l'aide promise par le
gouvernement
le reste sera examiné ultérieurement du
coup les marins à maintiennent la
pression à la veille d'une réunion avec
leur ministre de tutelle michel barnier
a paris une vingtaine de ports sont
bloqués c'est le cas ici à
boulogne-sur-mer où une opération
escargot a également été
ghani zay sur l'autoroute pas très loin
de là à cherbourg des pêcheurs ont fait
irruption dans des supermarchés pour
s'emparer est distribué aux passants des
poissons et des crustacés et puis on
l'évoquait déjà hier plusieurs dépôts de
carburants sont bloqués et du coup
certaines stations-service commence à
être à sec à la rochelle françois pris
20 fabien tormos blocus total à la
rochelle la zone de stockage de
carburant demeure inaccessible
les marins pêcheurs affichent leur
détermination on n'a plus rien à perdre
il faut rester là des témoins fragments
à leur mère pour la gagne et ça ne
rapporte plus rien en temps normal
400 semi remorques défilent chaque jour
au centre de distribution de carburant
il approvisionne une dizaine de
départements
désormais la situation se dégrade et on
redoute un enlisement du conflit des
pêcheurs on espère que des solutions
soient trouvées dans ce cas là nous
reprendrons une activité bon en deux
jours
assez rapidement on doit on devrait
pouvoir faire les les pleins d des sites
qui sont en rupture rupture de stock
depuis quelques heures dans de
nombreuses stations service de la
rochelle touché en premier lieu les
hypermarchés et les pompistes
indépendants sur les dépôts sont bloqués
donc on ne sait pas en question mission
de ce médecin cherche une station
ouverte en vain savoir quelle était la
station service réquisitionnées pour les
professions prioritaires et actuellement
il n'y a pas de stations services
réquisitionnées
on nous a dit qu'il y avait encore de
l'essence dans certaines stations qu'il
fallait chercher alors on se bouscule
aux pompes encore approvisionnées
le volume de carburant distribués a été
multiplié par 4 aujourd'hui
mais temps de travail permet cela
dans le courant de la nuit certaines
stations pourraient être
réapprovisionnées par du carburant en
provenance de bordeaux ou de la région
nantaise
on a parfois du mal à s'y retrouver dans
ce conflit entamé il ya plusieurs mois
les marins pêcheurs demandent vous le
savez l'application du plan de sauvetage
annoncé en janvier dernier
où en est on explication romain messi et
pourquoi j'ai un dialogue sans
concession début novembre au port du
guilvinec nicolas sarkozy rencontre les
pêcheurs en grève et en colère déjà en
raison du prix du carburant
six mois plus tard le problème reste
entier le litre de gazole payé 40
centimes d'euros début 2007
tout aujourd'hui 79 centimes les
pêcheurs ne s'en sortent plus pourtant
janvier dernier le gouvernement a
annoncé un plan daide pour la pêche
française 310 millions d'euros sur trois
ans dont 12 millions versés en urgence
problème
l'union européenne doit d'abord donner
son aval michel barnier à vous
aujourd'hui son impuissance
je ne peux rien faire la boîte à outils
que j'ai mis en place et que j'ai
présentées aux marins pêcheurs doit être
approuvé par bruxelles c'est une
condition sinequanone cet après midi
bruxelles a donné son feu vert à une
partie seulement du plan daide la
principale mesure 230 millions d'euros
pour moderniser les bateaux de pêche
reste pour l'heure en suspens et il faut
comprendre que cette crise du gazole
sert en fait de révélateur des
difficultés de la pêche française elle
doit faire face aux importations de plus
en plus massive et aussi au
développement de l'aquaculture qui a
fait un bond ces dernières années
reportage à gravelines dans le nord
valérie le rouge david fossard pas
besoin d'aller au large de dunkerque
pour trouver du poisson il suffit de se
pencher sur ces bassins ici les filets
ne sont pas dans l'eau mais au dessus
pour empêcher les oiseaux de se servir
la plus grande ferme aquacole de france
c'est 300 bassin et 2700 tonnes de
barres et de daurade produit chaque
année 20% de la consommation française
pour ce cours les poissons pas les
allemands à 2 g et après ils vont rester
dans la ferme à peu près 15 à 18 mois
pour atteindre une taille commerciale
300-350 là ils vont passer les abattent
un manfra mètres cubes 158 et au volant
l'eau de mer est ici enrichi en oxygène
est légèrement chauffé pour que les
poissons grandissent plus vite mais pas
besoin de dépenser du fuel pour ça l'eau
tiède est pompée directement à la sortie
de la centrale nucléaire d'à côté pour
le directeur de la ferme
ancien patron de la criée de lorient
l'élevage du poisson à bas coûts est
complémentaire de la pêche en mer
remplacera jamais la pêche puisque le
nombre d'espèces on est capable d'élever
sa sont économiquement viables en
agriculture est largement inférieur au
nombre d'espèces que la pêche est
capable d'apporter sur les marchés les
éleveurs veulent donc croire à la survie
des marins pêcheurs
il espère bien ne pas contribuer à les
affaiblir autre conflit qui touche les
ports français celui des dockers et des
grutiers des affrontements ont eu lieu
aujourd'hui à marseille le projet de
réforme est examinée en ce moment au
sénat et plusieurs ports sont touchées
par la grève
on évoquait la hausse du prix du gazole
et bien elle n'est pas près de se calmer
le cours du baril de pétrole a gagné
plus d'un dollar et demi aujourd'hui en
une seule journée en pulvérisant son
record 129 $ et 60 cents le baril on l'a
souvent dit la raison de cette envolée
tient à la hausse de la demande
notamment celle des pays émergents
du côté de l'offre la planète entière
des pandas cartel devenu fameux lors des
premier choc pétrolier l'opep 13 pays
qui détiennent les trois quarts des
ressources connues et qui refuse
d'ouvrir un peu plus les robinets
bernard lebrun lorsque le président
américain salue le ministre saoudien du
pétrole
c'est toujours avec beaucoup d'amabilité
et pour cause l'un et consommateurs
l'autre producteur
mais désormais le pouvoir a changé de
camp premier pays producteur de pétrole
au monde c'est le géant saoudien qui
décide
entouré du cartel des autres pays
membres de l'opep
l'opep l'organisation des pays
exportateurs
elle est créée en 1960 à l'initiative du
shah d'iran avec le venezuela et
l'arabie saoudite
aujourd'hui les 13 pays membres de
l'opep pèse 85 % des réserves mondiales
mais ne produit qu'un tiers de l'or noir
consommé dans le monde
autrement dit pensent les américains il
y a de la marge
à elle seule l'arabie saoudite produit
10 millions de barils par jour
mais le royaume est le seul pays au
monde à disposer d'une marge de
manoeuvre pour satisfaire la demande
il peut augmenter sa production mais il
s'y refuse désormais pour faire baisser
les prix
la demande ne cessant de croître de
chine comme des états unis les tarifs
vont inexorablement augmenté selon un
analyste financier américain les prix
dépasseront 140 dollars le baril dès la
fin de l'année
en france les prévisions de trafic pour
la grève de jeudi après demain au sujet
des retraites ont été communiquées le
mouvement commence en fait demain soir
très précisément à 20h bonsoir agnès
molinier vous êtes à la gare
montparnasse
à quoi faut-il s'attendre à écouter
david ans effectivement depuis cet après
midi que concernant les trains régionaux
en province comme en ile de france il
devrait y avoir un train sur 2 avec de
fortes disparités notamment la ligne c
du rer qui devrait être beaucoup plus
touchées concernant les grandes lignes
et les tgv il devrait y avoir deux
trains sur trois et sinon dans le métro
et le rer et bien il devrait y avoir
très peu de perturbations sauf sur la
ligne b et d du rer qui elles devraient
être fortement perturbés pour la sm7 je
vous rappelle les deux numéros de
téléphone que vous devez appeler pour
les grandes lignes d'abord le 0 805 90
36 35 et pour les lignes régionales
le 0 805 700 805
enfin sachez que dans le ciel il devait
y avoir très peu de perturbations sauf
peut-être selon la direction générale de
l'aviation civile
des perturbations peut être en début de
journée jeudi d'un mot agnès vous nous
dites qu'une grande part du trafic
restera assurée ce que cela a à voir
avec l'application pour la deuxième fois
du service minimum
absolument c'est la preuve le pro
gros conflit depuis l'application en
janvier de cette loi sur le service
garanti par servicemine on appelle ça un
service garanti
ce qui est nouveau c'est que les
salariés doivent se déclarer
deux jours avant le conflit ce qui
permet aux directions de la ratp et de
la sncf de redéployer les non grévistes
sur des lignes jugées prioritaires leur
but étant de faire rouler plus de trains
donc les prévisions sont plus précises
permettent d'afficher plus de trains au
départ jeudi
mais sachant cela on peut quand même
penser qu'avec des prévisions de 1 train
sur 2 trains sur 3 le mouvement semble
devoir quand même être suivi merci agnès
et noter que sur ce sujet sur ce conflit
et sur d'autres sujets françois fillon
sera notre invité demain dans ce journal
de 20 heures en bref une deuxième vague
de grèves de travailleurs sans papiers
un peu plus de 300 nouveaux salariés
clandestins entre guillemets ont cessé
le travail dans la région parisienne à
l'appel notamment de la cgt le mouvement
tu gagnes les régions manifestations
également ici à cannes depuis le début
du mouvement on estime que 70 personnes
sur les 900 qui en avait fait la demande
ont obtenu des papiers à l'étranger
naples a submergée par les ordures
attend la venue de silvio berlusconi le
premier conseil des ministres du nouveau
gouvernement se déroulera symboliquement
la bad main et il ya urgence les alertes
au feu se multiplient les habitants sont
excédés envoyés spéciaux philippe
visseyrias karine guillaumin toutes les
nuits naples offre le même spectacle des
montagnes de sacs poubelles incendiées
une quarantaine de feu la nuit dernière
une centaine la nuit d'avant et fusées
les pompiers cours de l'un à l'autre
pour faire face ils ont même reçu des
renforts venus d'autres régions d'italie
les gens pensent éliminer les ordures en
les incendiant mais ils ont tort car en
les brûlant et le libère des substances
toxiques qui sont nocives lorsqu'elles
ne sont pas incendier les ordures sont
renversés en travers de la route
aucun plan d'urgence n'est venu à bout
de la crise ni les des charges
supplémentaires dit les trains spéciaux
chargés d'ordures envoyé en allemagne
naples croule sous les déchets et les
habitants ont pris l'habitude de se
débarrasser ainsi de leurs ordures
on ne peut quand même pas les garder
chez nous c'est au pied du vésuve que
silvio berlusconi tiendra demain son
premier conseil des ministres il
pourrait annoncer l'intervention de
l'armée pour déblayer les rues j'espère
qu'il fera quelque chose pour nous il
nous l'a promis
parmi les pistes étudiées créé une
immense décharge dans la banlieue de
naples juste derrière ses toits pouvant
accueillir plusieurs centaines de
milliers de tonnes d'ordures
une proposition que les riverains
rejette pour bloquer l'accès au terrain
ils ont érigé plusieurs barrages et
veillent 24 heures sur 24 par crainte
d'une intervention policière dans les
sacs poubelles on trouve des déchets
toxiques des piles des médicaments car
les gens ne trie pas leurs ordures et
cela pollue notre sol demain pour
protester
ils manifesteront comme tant d'autres
dans le centre de naples pour accueillir
le gouvernement au grand complet
le centre ville a retrouvé un semblant
de propreté s'il prétend ne pas avoir de
baguette magique silvio berlusconi a
néanmoins promis de résoudre en quelques
semaines une crise des déchets qui dure
depuis 15 ans
les napolitains maintenant attendre du
concret à l'étranger encore nouvelle
étape des primaires démocrates aux états
unis les bureaux de vote ont ouvert dans
le kentucky on vote aussi mais par
correspondance dans l'orégon et barack
obama espère à cette occasion franchir
le cap de la majorité absolue de
délégués pour lui en tout cas l'affairé
déjà réglé il ne s'en prend plus à
hillary clinton
mais au candidat républicain déjà
désigné john mccain et qui fait
également sa cible principale du
sénateur résultat cette nuit en afrique
du sud le président thabo mbeki appelle
les habitants des bidonvilles de
johannesbourg à la fin des violences
contre les immigrés en l'évoqué tiers la
tension reste vive
treize mille personnes ont déjà fui ces
quartiers en france
on évoque souvent les effets de l'impôt
sur la fortune sur l'exil fiscal mais
les chiffres sont rares et bien ce
l'année 2006 ont été livrés aujourd'hui
les voici 843 redevables de l'isf ont
quitté la france il y a deux ans ces 26
% de plus qu'en 2005 cela représente un
manque à gagner de 144 millions d'impôts
pour le fisc mais dans le même temps 200
exilés serait rentré en france cette
année-là
depuis quelques mois de nouvelles
exonérations sont accordés à ceux qui
payent cet impôt sur la fortune
à condition d'investir dans des pme
européennes et du coup certaines d'entre
elles ont vu leur activité
décollez reportage higelin camathias
seconde une résidence principale en
bretagne une autre secondaire et
quelques biens locatifs
alain nico possède un patrimoine non
négligeable ce qui lui vaut de payer
lisf l'impôt de solidarité sur la
fortune
dans son cas 8000 euros une somme qu'il
ne paiera pas cette année car la loi
dite paquet fiscal voté l'été dernier
l'autorisent à investir cet argent dans
une pme
au lieu de payer l'impôt je prends un
risque c'est pas une fuite
c'est l'investissement cdc des pme etc
la bretagne c'est des emplois c'est
l'économie pour placer son argent dans
les pme de sa région il s'est adressé au
fonds d'investissement de bretagne un
fonds de proximité gérés par des
professionnels du capital qui
investissent dans des pme prometteuses
les gestionnaires qui profitent
pleinement des nouvelles mesures
fiscales
d'abord groupe élargi notre clientèle le
souscripteur est facile augmenter les
montants souscrits
parce que les plafonds de déduction de
bsr sont portés sur le jusqu'à 20000
euros et donc ça augmente l option
moyennant façon très sensible en huit
mois les fonds levés atteignent 10
millions d'euros l'argent est investi
dans différentes entreprises comme celle
ci spécialisée dans les engrais
biologique
la société vient d'homologuer un produit
révolutionnaire totalement naturel pour
lutter contre la maladie de la vigne
marché potentiel 60 millions d'euros
une réussite qui n'auraient pas été
possibles sans l'investissement du fonds
de proximité
sans ce dernier coup de pouce on aurait
eu du mal à financer ne serait-ce que
les frais administratifs de gestion de
ce dossier qui sont très élevés les cinq
cent mille foyers assujettis à l isf ont
jusqu'au mois de juin pour se décider
si tous choisissent d'investir dans des
pme ce sera la fin de l'impôt sur la
fortune
la politique avec d'abord cette dernière
minute l'assemblée nationale vient dapd
trouver la version définitive du projet
de loi ogm auxerre en vous le voyez d'un
débat tendu et dans une ambiance
survoltée avec des incidents de séance
le sénat doit voter à son tour jeudi
ségolène royal poursuit ses déplacements
vue de la campagne pour le contrôle du
parti socialiste elle était aujourd'hui
en visite sur un site symbole celui
d'arcelormittal à gandrange
elle a apporté son soutien aux grévistes
jeff vite imbert patrice brugère sur
place on se protège en politique comme
dans la sidérurgie et dans les deux cas
aussi on bat le fer quand il est chaud
ségolène royal profite d'un regain
d'attention 40 journalistes les suivent
aujourd'hui nous sommes près de
gandrange est là où nicolas sarkozy
s'était engagé à sauver arcelormittal ya
eu des promesses qui ont été faites par
que sarkozy et mita lançant par ces deux
messieurs qui aujourd'hui ne tiennent
pas leurs promesses
la visite a été bien baliser les
syndicalistes que rencontre ségolène
royal n'en ont que pour nicolas sarkozy
et le circuit continue devant l'usiné
mittal bloqué depuis une semaine le
piquet de grève de la cgt fait recette
olivier besancenot est venu le premier
plutôt bienveillant pour ségolène royal
si la gauche est capable de redécouvrir
schéma des usines ce sera tant mieux
certains ouvriers se montrent plus
réalistes et sa bataille à elle la
bataille des éléments autres que les
treizistes l'endroit lui semble pourtant
bien choisi pour lancer sa campagne
interne
et peu importe les remous ne veulent pas
des gains d'échelle n'en n'auront pas
j'en serai la garante les deux ou trois
personnalités du parti et qui parle un
peu fort ne représente pas à la
profondeur du parti socialiste candidate
déclarée aussitôt sur le terrain
ségolène royal a pris une longueur
d'avancé celle qu'elle a perdu dans les
sondages pour l'instant sur bertrand
delanoë son principal concurrent la
gauche et la droite qui se sont
retrouvés côte à côte une fois n'est pas
coutume sur un terrain de football
françois hollande et pierre sarkozy dans
la même équipe
un match était organisé tout à l'heure
de l'association france alzheimer et
l'énigme a dit diawara va déjà bien
échauffée cet après midi à l'assemblée
fin prêt comme à l'assemblée les
politiques changent de costume vous avez
dû 8 cl seul le terrain sportif pour la
bonne cause la lutte contre la maladie
d'alzheimer
une fois n'est pas coutume gouvernement
et opposition sous un même maillot mais
chacun aborde le match avec leslie ce
parc
on joue ensemble je crois donc comme
difficile de jouer contre son camp au
pouvoir on va pousser dans le même sens
ça c'est bon on joue avec tout le monde
l'attend on va vers une cause comme
celle là on fait pas la différence on
regarde pas sur les transferts de
l'année est déjà un premier tacle
aussitôt suivi d'un autre je serai
peut-être la différence d'autres de ne
pas marquer de but contre mon camp oui
visé leur coéquipier eric besson ex
socialiste entrée au gouvernement fillon
il joue en défense
je joue arrière droit parce que le poste
d'arrière gauche n'était pas libre non
mais je suis peut-être celui qui
effectivement connaît le plus de monde
dans l'équipe
autre surprise le fils du chef de l'état
pierre sarkozy
ils jouent contre les politiques avec
les people et les sportifs aussi le
sujet parfois restés trop longtemps que
l'an passé stéphane a voulu jouer en
défense premier changement décidé par
l'entraîneur gérard houllier
les socialistes entrent en action parmi
les supporters roselyne bachelot est
inquiète
j'espère qu'on va pas avoir trop de
blessures espérons pour l'instant déjà
une moisson de bus 2 pour les politiques
4 pour leurs adversaires la fondation
france alzheimer qui récoltent 60000
euros est à noter toujours en politique
que bruno mégret annonce son retrait de
la vie politique il indique qu'il va
partir travailler à l'étranger
l'éducation c'est en ce moment que se
décident les inscriptions pour la
prochaine rentrée scolaire dans
l'enseignement secondaire vous le savez
la carte scolaire a été assouplie cela
signifie qu'on peut demander pour ses
enfants un établissement qui n'est pas
forcément près de chez soi
quelle est la règle quelles sont les
marges de manoeuvre aujourd'hui
nabila taboury vivien roussel
pour céline et sa maman l'inscription en
classe de seconde est un long parcours
première étape le choix du lycée le taux
de réussite au bac les options proposées
le temps de transport
elle passe tout en revue problème celui
ci qui dans leur secteur géographique
est loin d'être celui de leurs rêves
il n'a pas une excellente réputation on
en fils y est allé la première année
j'avais fait fille de steven scolaire a
entendu dire et le résultat n'a pas été
probant
seule solution une demande de dérogation
pour ce lycée du centre-ville de nice 91
% de réussite au bac
c'est l'un des trois meilleurs de
l'académie c'est aussi l'un des plus
demandés
rendez vous est pris avec le proviseur
pour un entretien qui ne garantit pas
une inscription votre demande
le frère de céline ayant déjà obtenu une
dérogation dans ce lycée l'an dernier
elle pourrait bénéficier d'un
rapprochement de fratrie
car pour éviter tout risque de
passe-droit un système de critères a été
instauré la proximité géographique reste
la règle
un élève sera automatiquement inscrit
dans son établissement de secteur une
dérogation est nécessaire dans le cas
contraire sont prioritaires les élèves
handicapés ou malades
les boursiers les lycéens ayant une
orientation spécifique ou encore les
fratries dans certaines académies les
notes peuvent aussi compter
au lycée calmette près de 5 % des élèves
ont obtenu une dérogation l'an dernier
mais le proviseur ne peut pas accueillir
tout le monde
on a des
des plafonds d'accueil ne serait ce que
par la capacité réelle des classes au
delà de 35 ans ne peut pas installer une
chaîne supplémentaire tout bêtement les
demandes de dérogations doivent être
déposées d'ici fin mai l'an dernier 13
1500 familles ont fait la démarche
une grande majorité a obtenu
satisfaction toujours à propos
d'éducation mais au sens plus large du
terme voici une expérience qui va sans
doute intéresser beaucoup de parents
elle est menée en alsace pour les 250
enfants d'une école ils vont passer dix
jours dix jours sans télévision sans
jeux vidéo et sans ordinateur l'objectif
est simple une prise de conscience de la
présence envahissante des écrans c'est
le dossier de cette émission il est
signé josé blanc lapierre et abdel we
wish l'école a dit oui ces lignes
ordinateur ni console de jeux avant
décidé d'essayer pendant les dix jours
qui viennent de ne plus regarder la
télévision
pas facile quand on sait qu'à 10 11 ans
ils sont scotchés aux écrans en moyenne
quatre heures par jour tous les midis
tous les soirs je vais rater les juin
veille
je suis toute tension au piment café le
but trouver d'autres idées pour se
distraire après les devoirs et les noter
dans un carnet de bord il entendit jour
elle est vécue et avoir un oeil critique
sur ce qui le regarde et pas seulement à
consommer la télévision tels qu'ils le
font peut-être actuellement pierre 9 ans
n'arrêterai jamais un peu d'ordi puis
télé en passant par la game boy
à croire qu'il ne s'est pas se distraire
autrement plus d'écran pendant la
semaine
sa maman a déjà essayé pas vraiment un
succès le joueur touchera 30 juin ma ds
et qu'il est un peu trop tard lundi
dépêche-toi détente demain c'est l'école
est tu sais bien qu'ils que tu dois pas
y jouer en semaine les écrans ont envahi
la maison portable dvd ordinateur il y
en a parfois dans toutes les pièces et
pour certains spécialistes de l'enfant
enfin le problème est la façon de
regarder
ce qui est dramatique aujourd'hui c'est
pas un appartement où chacun est dans sa
pièce devant sa télé ça c'est terrible
parce qu'il n'y a plus de communication
familiale et quand ils buttent
communication familiale
il peut pas y avoir d'autorité d'après
une étude réalisée auprès d'élèves de 5e
les images auraient plus ou moins
d'influx ans en fonction de l'état
psychologique de l'enfant
à un moment donné aux parents donc
d'être attentifs quant aux consoles de
jeu contrairement aux idées reçues
certains y voient même des avantages se
dire que le geste interactif est une
manière de jouer de manipuler les images
et donc de se les approprier
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
moi-même j'utilise le jeu vidéo comme
médiation thérapeutiques pour des
enfants qui ont des troubles du
comportement violent
habitué aux images depuis le biberon
les enfants seraient plus malins qu'on
ne le pense pour faire la part entre
réalité virtuelle
à condition bien sûr de consommer avec
modération à qui ou à quoi ressemblaient
vraiment jules césar une équipe
d'archéologues a découvert lors d'une
campagne de fouilles près d'arles à un
buste en marbre d'un mètre 87 une pièce
unique elle constitue la seule
représentation connue de césar réalisé
de son vivant
frédéric monteil des fouilles
archéologiques arles en a connu des
centaines autour de son forum ou de ces
arènes
mais la plus grande découverte de ces
cinquante dernières années vient du
fleuve le rhône en septembre dernier en
face du centre historique
une équipe d'archéologues a localisé une
épave d'époque romaine
à dix mètres de fond une vingtaine
d'objets parfaitement conservés et
surtout ce portrait d'une valeur
exceptionnelle
jules césar il n'existe que deux autres
buts au monde de ce type
la découverte est stocké dans le plus
grand secret sur ce bateau c'est la
première fois que des scientifiques
trouvent un buste de jules césar en
marbre aussi réaliste l'empereur
représentait trait pour trait luan des
orientations divinisé de césar on a
affaire ici un portrait très expressif
jeune homme âgé et il ya toutes les
chances que ce portrait était fait de
son mieux
peut-être d'ailleurs au moment où il a
fondé tout simplement où il a créé cette
ville d'arles
la découverte a été validé par des
historiens de l'art et des experts en
morphologie médico légal reste un
mystère
pourquoi ce buste dorment est-il au beau
milieu du rhône hypothèse la statue
aurait été jeté dans le fleuve après
l'assassinât de l'empereur
car il ne faisait pas bon alors être
considéré comme un de ses partisans un
document du magazine des racines et des
ailes qui sera diffusé demain soir sur
france 3 avec donc d'autres images et
d'autres informations sur ce bus à
cannes l'image du jour c'est la montée
des marches très glamour ce soir de
sharon stone d'abord qui est venu pour
le plaisir
suivi de l'équipe du film du nous
film de clint eastwood avec entre autres
angelina jolie qui étaient avec nous
vendredi dernier clint eastwood en
compétition pour la cinquième fois son
film s'appelle les changes avec pour
toile de fond
l'amérique des années 20 marijuana
d'indycar sur place ils dénoncent la
justice l éthique aussi glam s'engager
lecouffe impressionne en selle des
jumeaux angelina jolie a tenu à assurer
leur promotion du film parce qu'il
aborde et celle récente sans manger
l'histoire est tirée d'un fait divers
des années 20 angelina incarne une mère
célibataire dont l'enfant a disparu et
qui va mettre en pause la police
corrompue du los angeles de 1928
grâce à sa ténacité cette femme a fait
voler en éclats non seulement la police
de los angelès mais aussi l'appareil
politique
le maire n'a pas été réélu bien qu'elle
soit seule femme on sait je sais où tu
iras cette époque n'a jamais renoncé
chez jusqu'à quand
parce que ça
ouais
pollution
j'ai perdu ma mère quelques mois avant
le film pour moi ces familles ressentent
énormément
sa mère était soumise après la paresse
mais si on touche ici avec les enfants
elle devenait une vraie l'yonne
aujourd'hui ma jolie elle est tellement
incroyable bugs et joue avec les
sentiments des spectateurs et du tout
aimé du tout cas classique mais une
bonne histoire très bien interprété du
coup clint eastwood son vingtième film
le 31 mai il aura soixante dix huit ans
j'ai encore une semaine alors laissez
moi tranquille avec ça avant de refermer
ce journal je vous en rappelle l'un des
principaux titres pour la première fois
la justice reconnaît le droit opposable
au logement en fin d'après midi le
tribunal administratif de paris a donné
raison à une familles mal logées dont le
dossier avait été rejeté sur ce plateau
tout à l'heure christine boutin ministre
du logement se félicitait de cette
décision ce n'est qu'à la fin de l'année
que les familles pourront vraiment
s'appuyer sur ce principe pour faire
condamner l'état ou une collectivité
locale
en cas de non obtention d'un logement
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi tout de suite la météo
laurent romejko 20h50 un nouveau
magazine autour de jean luc delarue tout
quitter pour changer de vie à demain
d'info continue
c'est aussi sur france 2 point fr
oui